One issue that can come up if we write
a really good random test-case generator
is that we can be overwhelmed by
the success of our own bug-finding effort.
On some level we should be so
lucky to have this problem,
but on the other hand if you take
a large software project
that's never been subjected
to random testing,
and hit it with a sophisticated
random tester
it's not at all unexpected that you'll be
overwhelmed by the number of bugs.
What'll happen is you'll start
a random testing run.
You will leave for the weekend and
next time you come in
there might be 250 bugs.
The way we want to visualize
the situation is like this.
We have the input domain of course and
all I'm going to show here are inputs that found bugs.
There's a bunch of them.
What we have is a fundamental quandary,
which is the question
do we have 250 test inputs that all,
for one reason or another,
happen to map to the same bugging output,
or on the other hand, do we have a situation
where we found, perhaps,
250 different bugs.
Without looking in more detail at what's going on
there's no way we can tell.
Most likely--almost certainly--the truth is in the middle.
Almost certainly we found 10 bugs or maybe 50 bugs,
but we probably didn't get so lucky as to find 250 bugs.
We probably weren't so unlucky as to trigger
the same bug 250 times,
although, of course, that kind of thing does happen.
There are basically two ways out of this problem.
The first solution--pick a bug and report it.
It's totally irrelevant which bug it is.
It could be a random bug.
Most likely what we'd want to do is
eyeball them a little bit somehow
and see which one seems the most serious.
It doesn't matter.
Let's say we report this test case here,
so that goes to our developers.
What they're going to do is fix it, of course.
This buggy part of the output space
goes away in the next version of the system.
Now we don't have range of the system.
We have range prime, which is just
the range of the next version.
So, we still have exactly the same input space
but the behavior of the software under test
has changed a little bit.
Now something interesting happens.
Not only did that particular failure go away,
but perhaps some of the other ones did.
Perhaps all of these over here stopped being inputs
that trigger failures anymore.
Of course that's great, because it's nice
to see that they fixed a bug
that covers such a large part of the input space.
On the other hand, another possibility is all of the
remaining bug-triggering inputs
that we found still trigger bugs, and so what do we do?
Well, of course, we just go ahead and report another bug.
This strategy will keep working.
As soon as we get a new version of the system
that fixes a bug we've reported,
we can just do another one.
This isn't a bad mode of operation.
What this works for is
basically for smallish systems
where bugs can be fixed rather quickly,
there's no problem at all
reporting one bug at a time.
On the other hand, if the people
fixing bugs have a slow fix cycle--
let's say we're only testing actual released
versions of Microsoft Word, for example--
we're only getting a new version
every couple of years.
If they fix one bug in Microsoft Word
every couple of years,
the question is how long do we think
that'll take for them to arrive at
a correct version of Microsoft Word?
The answer, of course, is they never will,
because they're putting bugs in
faster than we would take them out,
using a one-bug-at-a-time model.
This can easily be the case for real
software products.
If that's the situation, if reporting one
bug at a time doesn't work,
we're forced to use a different strategy.
I call that bug triage.